étrangère
[Musique]
route ouverte vous aide à penser à où
vous allez
où vous étiez
depuis la première nuit nous avons rencontré ma part ce que
le fruit
et vous appartiennent
nous avions l'habitude de vivre notre vie sur un quart de
mile à la fois
mais les choses changent
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
tu conduis comme ton père
[Musique]
peur de perdre quelqu'un J'aime
ta famille est tellement impressionnant
à quel point je suis bon mais c'est ton dernier
trajet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as fait une erreur jamais pensé que la
famille de mon Homme était
géniale  Dawn Toretto comment choisissez-vous ceux que
vous
nous avez sauvés pourraient ne pas revenir de tout ce
que nous avons fait rien de tout cela ne
vaut une chose si je te perds
si c'est la ligne d'arrivée
[Musique]
chevauche ou meurs souviens-toi de
la promesse
étrangère
[  Musique]